I've always been fascinated by the
thought process and the backstory of
people who have done remarkable things
yoni obviously led a mission that was
probably one of the greatest raised in
history and we had access and i had read
when I was younger his book of letters
and you see a lot of them here in the
film and that to me was a reason to tell
this story because it's very rare that
you get such an insight and and you see
the conflicts and the heart and the soul
and the the turmoil that went on and
raged inside of him while he was making
these choices and making the the the
dedication to his country paramount in
his life and yoni is a very inspiring
character to me he he's a person who
probably should have been very
self-absorbed he was a remarkable
athlete a lot of people don't know that
in in Philadelphia he was actually the
star athlete with Reggie Jackson the two
of them were the star athletes in their
class he was a brilliant academic breeze
through Harvard he was obviously a very
good-looking guy as well and he had
every reason to be selfish and I think
the remarkable aspect about him was that
he was constantly putting it pushing
aside those selfish drives and seeking a
higher purpose and serving a higher
purpose and coming to the defense of his
country and I think in any any country I
think it's remarkable that a person does
that and I feel like with the letters
you really get an insight into the
conflicts and the trade-offs and the
sacrifices that these types of people go
through and it was just a remarkable
opportunity to tell this this great
story but you know we wanted to tell
this story as a very personal story we
wanted it not to be a political story we
wanted it to be a story of a young man
sacrificing himself for a higher cause
and the conflicts and trade-offs that
came along with that
and for us to be able to get the funding
it through somebody who didn't have
connections with the family politically
and somebody who would be able to really
let us capture this story I was I the
person who financed the film and help
finance the film took the lead is Mark
Manson he's a former Wall Street person
and he's a remarkable man who I was
financing we have a feature film fund in
England together and I was sitting with
him in a restaurant and he just asked me
what other projects I was interested in
making and I told him about the story he
had no connection to the story he had no
real interest never had heard of yoni
Netanyahu before and I talked to him
about it and I explained to him my
thoughts and he fell in love with the
story he saw it as a love triangle
between a young man his family and the
loves of his life and his country and
when he figured that out and he
understood that I really thought this is
the person who we should make the film
with because that's the kind of film we
wanted to make the other amazing thing
was and it was a surprise because as
most people know when you go into
documentaries and you don't know exactly
what you're going to get out of the
interviews and the interviews are the
bedrock of the film so we were telling a
story that was 35 years old and we had
no idea if when we got on the ground and
talked to the soldiers who were there or
the family or his wife and girlfriends
if they were going to be able to relive
in an emotional way in a compelling way
this story you know his life and it was
very nerve-racking when we got there and
I think after a few of the interviews
especially with the Prime Minister and
2d and Beria who's where's all of her
emotions on her sleeve we really felt
like we had something because again as a
testament to yoni these people think
about him feel him every single day well
I have I have four kids my oldest son is
actually named after yoni he's 14 years
old and as I said before you know
they're living in a culture of me you
know they're living in a culture of what
can I do for my success in my career and
you know just every day how can I make
myself happy and hopefully here's a role
model who shows them that there is a
there's a greater purpose in life
whether it's for your country whether
it's for your community you know whether
it's for you know African children
whatever the cause might be hopefully
this at least opens their eyes and I
think Americans in general opens their
eyes to seeing the world outside of them
and not just being